time has run out for Northern Ireland to
restore its devolved government
last-ditch efforts to break the
political deadlock have failed
so Northern Ireland must now head back
to the polls
I hear it when parties say that they
really do not want an election at all
but nearly all of them were parties who
signed up to the rules the the law that
means I need to call an election so
you'll hear more from me on that
particular Point next week the heart of
the disagreement is the Northern Ireland
protocol it's the part of the UK's
post-brexit deal with the EU that's
resulted in a trade border between
Northern Ireland and the rest of the UK
to avoid a hard border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland
which is in the EU for the dup one of
the assembly's two main power sharing
parties this is unacceptable they
believe Northern Ireland and the UK are
indivisible there's not a single
unionist who supports the protocol so it
falls by the very definition that the
British government and even the EU have
defined as progress in Northern Ireland
where people have to work together to
make that progress in February the dup
pulled out of the power sharing
executive collapsing it and since
elections in May the dup has blocked
efforts to get things moving again other
parties in the Stormont assembly are
unimpressed I feel angry about what I
saw yesterday in the in the assembly
chamber Peter McReynolds is from the
alliance party which tries to bridge
divisions between Nationalist and
unionist communities election is going
to change nothing the people of Northern
Ireland said what they wanted six months
ago I think if there's going to be an
election in the coming weeks they're
going to say the exact same thing again
and it's actually going to entrench the
division that we now have have
generations of political violence all
but finished with the 1998 Good Friday
agreement it established power sharing
across the sectarian divide and
prohibited any hard border with Ireland
to the South all of this is now in
danger
Northern Ireland's political paralysis
is one of the most serious aftershocks
from the earthquake set off by brexit
the traps that brexit laid for peace and
politics in Northern Ireland were
predicted and are now playing out it's
going to take immense effort from
Belfast to Brussels from London to
Dublin to sort all of this out Rory
challans Al Jazeera Belfast